bring in Daniel Jeremiah NFL Network
analyst and former NFL scout you sent
out a tweet yesterday and it kind of
sums up what it's like at this time of
the year with the NFL Draft Daniel there
are so many rumors here and you're
trying to sort through it you were a
former NFL scout do you have a go-to guy
or go-to guys that you know they're
gonna give you the as honest of opinion
as possible yeah but it's a few and far
between Dan it's you're talking about
maybe two or three guys that you've
known for for twenty years are gonna lie
to you and on the other side of that I'm
not going to probe them on on what
they're going to do and ask for specific
names but they they don't lie to me and
and you get some good information and
then you get some stuff like I had the
other day where within 20 minutes I
talked to two different general managers
once that you know the Redskins are
moving up for Haskins and I said okay
that's interesting and then 20 minutes
later I said that you know the Redskins
are moving up and I go yeah yeah Jones
your favorite rumor you've heard is what
well the drew Locke one you know that
Tennessee could consider Trulock you've
got Marcus Mariota coming to the last
year of his contract and it sounded
really you know kind of far-fetched to
me I don't I think though if I go to a
year a prove-it year and see what he can
do but I did a radio interview yesterday
with the Nashville station and they said
right after that tweet had come out they
were going to interview drew Locke and
they said what about the Titans and it
said look like you saw a ghost and he
said well I spent you know two different
meetings with them they worked me out
you know they gave me one plate of a
remember on the first meeting and I came
back and I thought I did a good job
I love the quarterback coach it was like
oh wait a second there is something here
Wow
if you're the Cardinals GM what are you
doing tonight I'm turning in the card
for Nick Bosa
or Quentin Williams and I wouldn't have
a problem with what either one of them I
think it's a one a would be thing I
would continue to try and develop Josh
Rosen and give him some help I think
he's got tremendous talent but you know
I look it's a unique situation with the
connection with Kyler Murray and Kliff
Kingsbury and you've started down that
road so I can understand them going in
that direction but if I was in the chair
stuck with rosin and got one of those
defensive linemen why would you pass on
Murray oh well I have a higher grade
that higher grade on Josh Rosen coming
out landed on Tyler Perry so so there
you go I would continue to try and give
him a chance
nobody had a chance with what he had
last year nobody with all the turmoil
there's no chance he was going to be
successful it just is a little premature
to punt on him in my opinion where do
you have Cuyler Murray on your big board
number 11 he's my top quarterback and
the ceiling is very high I mean you
could you could hit it fake but
obviously it comes with some risk so I
would stack him behind the top three
guys I had in last year's draft which
word Arnold Rosen Mayfield we were
talking about this prior to the show
that yet you know the best player in the
draft is rarely the number one player
taken right yeah now we look at position
grade we look at need because I thought
I thought Nelson going to the I thought
Nelson was the best player in the draft
last year yeah I think I had him at
number two Dan I think I had fake one
you know and again this is by great not
saying what you would you know if you
have a needed quarterback you take a
good quarterback over a great player if
you don't have one what's unique about
the Cardinals is I think they have one
so yeah but normally the best player is
not the highest graded player does not
end up being the first pick because
there's such an importance placed on a
couple other positions but if I said to
the Giants you can redraft
from last season if I make you to the GM
and you can redraft or you can take sake
one Barkley you got the second pick who
are you taking I would take Sam Donald I
said it last year and I say that same
Barkley was my number one player in that
draft I think Donald was number four or
five but that's because you had some
special players up there but as a
quarterback I thought I'd only had a
chance to be really really good and he's
21 years old he's gonna be your guy for
the next 15 16 years you know LT did you
know LP is a hall-of-famer lt's not one
of the best running backs of all time
he's in the same teams in the same
classes drew brees lt's been working at
the NFL network for a while drew Brees
is still going
I just so you know what Nelson is he's
an all-pro lineman you know what's a
Kwan Barclay is he's an all-pro running
back we don't know what Sam darn 'old is
but your philosophy is still you would
take Sam Darnell the quarterback over
those proven players if you have
conviction on the quarterback we don't
know really truthfully what any of these
guys are going to be but if you have a
great on a quarterback that says he can
an upper tier starter at the NFL I'd you
have to you have to go with your
conviction you got to trust your
evaluation if that's what you feel
you've got to do it you know if you
don't have a quarterback it is hard to
have sustained success so when you've
got yourself in position to get one of
those upper tier guys I don't think you
pass on it we're talking to Daniel
Jeremiah the NFL Network former NFL
scout the quarterback you have the most
concerns about is oh gosh there's none
of these guys that are that are clean
that's a tough one
I would say drew Locke is someone who
has tremendous upside he throws it as
well as anybody but he's got some habits
he needs to continue to work through the
work outside makes me nervous though
Daniel up side always makes me no
absolutely up sides got a lot of people
fired but when you can when you can
drive the ball like he does he's got a
tremendous arm he's a very good athlete
he watched the Florida game and use a
top five pick but there's other games
where he just he locks on some targets
he's late with the ball he's a little
bit adventurous he's got some footwork
stuff that needs to be cleaned up he to
me is he's not Pat mahomes but he needs
the Pat mahomes treatment in that get
him to a team with a good veteran
quarterback let him sit let him continue
to work and develop on the practice
field and eventually I think you'd have
a really nice payoff I think it would it
would not be in his best interest to go
somewhere and get thrown right on the
field where's the drama tonight which
team I mean I think it starts at 3:00
because the Jets have been calling
everybody and their mother trying to get
out of number three so that's where I
think we see some action taking place so
whether or not they can get out if they
can't get out you know you hear that
Greg Williams is lobbying for it all
over
there's other people in the building
that love Quinn and Williams Josh Allen
edge rusher is probably their number-one
needs so they could go with three
different players or get out of there so
that's where the drama starts you trust
Oakland to stay with what they need and
you know not reach not do anything crazy
or do you look at Gruden in May I can go
you know what I wouldn't be surprised I
know what Mike wants to do you know he
wants to get his words get foundational
players I mean this is kind of a it's a
culture draft it's three guys you can't
miss on don't swing for the fences just
put it in the foot in the middle of the
fairway here good solid players you're
not looking to replace and they can go
with you to Vegas and be a part of a
winning culture but this is just I think
you just try and find three really
reliable dependable eliminate the risk
in this draft if I'm the Raiders are you
a Derek karst am i Derek Carr gets
bounced I was that reason are you pro
car Oh Pro car I'm sorry the look I
stacking him up with with this
quarterback class yes yes I know the you
know you got to factor in the money
aspect of it but man I attempted hey but
you've got Antonio Brown now you've got
an opportunity to get a running back in
this draft if it's the first round
second round whatever add support pieces
around him
let's see you went on paid a bunch of
money to an offensive tackle you've got
him some help let's see if you can play
in this system to see what you can do
I'd wanna I'd want to get another look
at it before I decide to move on what
did the Giants do tonight everything you
hear you know these might guilty
pleasures and oh these pre-draft press
conferences because and I'll text the
GM's afterwards ago that was masterful
as you said absolutely not answer one
question well done but gentleman's like
the one that's like fired like exactly
what he thinks last year he said point
blank I want a gold jacket player I want
I'm going to take the best player
regardless of position it's the
discussion we just had and suppose all
signs pointed to sake want Barkley he's
the best player the graph
Oh bleep and that's what he did he
didn't take a quarterback in and this
year he's basically doubled down and
said I'm not gonna move a quarterback
over somebody else at another position
if we have higher graded and where they
are at six I just I can't see it that
they're gonna have a quarterback at the
top of their board so it would be it
would be very unusual to have an older
car a quarterback on your roster you
could replace in two years in a row
passing on a quarterback in the top ten
but based on his words I expect that's
what they'll do yeah but if I love a
quarterback I'm not waiting till 17
Daniel if I love him it at 17 you know I
got to love him at 6 - and if I don't
love him at 6 then you know I'm not I'm
not going to take him what do you think
of that philosophy yeah I will stick
with the relationship analogy and say
it's a difference between like and love
and if she will take him at 6 you want
to marry him if you take him at 17
you're dating dating him so I don't know
if you like a guy I was talking to
somebody the other day about this about
your Biscay and he said you know look
even Jacksonville when they took portals
I didn't didn't end up ultimately
working out if you think he can be your
quarterback your franchise quarterback
or if you don't like that word you're
dependable starting quarterback for the
next decade there's no such thing as
over drafting it you can't so if you
want to don't worry about what the rest
of the world thinks just take him he's
gonna be your guy you're gonna get if
you take him at 6 and he doesn't work
out you're gonna get fired
if you take him at 17 and he doesn't
work out you're also going to get fired
get the one you want the biggest whiff
you ever had the player that you love
that didn't work out was who Oh every
year at draft time it all comes back to
me I just hear injury I mean it wasn't
even just that I gave her and curry a
good grade they've said I can remember
being in the draft room and you know as
a young ignorant Scout like almost
pontificating like guys yeah look at my
for 2 or 3 years I've been doing this
there's no chance this guy this is I
mean there's there's some good players
in this draft but you know this guy you
know he's gonna get a gold jacket it
can't miss no brainer just turn in the
car don't even think about it yeah I
didn't go so well he had five career
sacks Daniel does that what no is he
eligible
I don't know we'll check on that I think
he probably needs another 150 more sacks
but other than that check that out
hey have fun tonight and always great to
check in with you thank you you're the
best thank you Daniel Jeremiah NFL
Network analyst former NFL scout and NFL
Network's live coverage of the 2019 NFL
Draft from Nashville starts at 8:00
Eastern
coming up tonight for more Dan Patrick
show tune in to audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV streamed for free on VR live or
download the Dan Patrick show app